you ready go for it you let me know go
for captain
you let me know when it's when right now
just go like that
greetings from podcastville uncle joey's
joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen to me the biggest
college basketball tournament
of the year is heating up you got to get
off the [__] couch
and get into the tournament action all
right here's what i got for you this
week are you ready for this one
you bet four bucks on an underdog any
[__] underdog
if they win you're up 256 dollars
that's 64 to one odds that's [__]
insanity you understand me
but that's draftkings it's fun it's easy
who's gonna win think you know well all
it takes is four bucks to get a shot at
winning
256 dollars
the atm is spitting out 20s like when i
used to do that bank in the 80s 82 when
i used to
anyway it don't matter there's no way
there's no better way
to put your college basketball knowledge
to the test and to put your money where
your [__] mouth is
right or wrong and that's when draftking
sportsbook comes in
college ball ain't for you you're
[__] out of your mind
four dollars wins you 256 dollars you
better get a quick [__] education
from one of your buddies
but if it's not for you i understand but
listen draftking sportsbook offers other
great [__] odds and promotions on
hockey
nba golf and much much more with a
tremendous
online casino draftkings is safe secure
and reliable withdraw your money when
you want
it's your [__] money who's
better than you
you get your dick sucked you could do
whatever you want
you understand me but it all starts by
you downloading the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app
now right now right now stop [__]
around use promo code joey
when you sign up you turn four dollars
into 256 [__] dollars are you kidding
me or what
even if you went out and played the
local lottery that you
and they ain't gonna give you that
though anyway
pick the underdog of your choosing to
pull the upset just
[__] bet against gonzaga that's what
i'm gonna do
every week i'm gonna be back just bet
against gonzaga until they [__]
crumble you know what i'm saying that
you can't go 31-1
or 31-0 i think larry bird's team was 31
but it don't matter download the
draftking sports book app now
use promo code joey and get a chance of
putting four dollars
into 256 dollars for a limited
time only at draftking sportsbook now
here's the part the lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 older
take your [__] kazoo and shove it up
your ass new jersey indiana pennsylvania
tennessee colorado got some gambling new
customers only
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gambling palm i don't want you [__]
around you know what i'm saying
call 1-800 gambler or if you're in
indiana
call 1-809 with it deal with your help
but if you're [__] ready to make some
cash
and get your balls linked this weekend
download the draftking sports book app
listen you can't show up in a girl's
house i got no money for fly
yeah listen i'm giving you the sure shot
solution right here
four dollars gets you 256 dollars
drop download the draftking sportsbook
app now
and tell them your uncle joey sent you
you understand me now
the joint is also brought to you by
gabby insurance
gabby g-a-b-i we're all looking for ways
to save our money right
especially now everybody's waiting for
that small 1400
that's gonna come and go like you know
so let me ask you this how'd you like a
little extra 961 dollars a year in your
pocket
if i could save you 961 dollars per year
what would you do that's how much gabby
customers save per year on their car and
home
insurance before i go looking for
insurance
i talk to gabby that's who's insuring me
now in jersey
on my car compare what you got and 40
top other insurance providers
like progressive nationwide and
travelers just link your current
insurance account
and in two minutes you'll be able to see
quotes from the exact same
coverage you currently have listen man
i was living in l.a i didn't know when i
moved here i was looking for different
insurance they gave me a binder one day
i i worked with gabby before i said let
me give them a try
my wife says i'm saving a ton of money
from what i was paying before on my car
so what i'm trying to say it's easy only
take one minute to take a look at what
these savages got the next round is on
me gabby customers saved 961
per year on average i bet you'd like
that in your pocket
now if you can't if they can't find you
the savings
they'll let you know so you can relax
knowing that you have the best rate out
there nobody else does that for you
gabby does so do me a favor you're
probably overpaying on your car and home
insurance
see how much gabby can save just take a
look what's it gonna hurt
right now the times are rough it's
totally free to check
and there's no obligation so go to
gabby.com
uncle joey that's gabbygabi.com
uncle joey and it's totally free to
check it out there's no obligation
if you could save two three hundred four
hundred nine hundred dollars
who's better than you especially at
these times so go to gabby
dot com slash uncle joey and save some
money with insurance
let's get this podcast going now that's
it it's wednesday
happy with saint patty's day to
everybody
let's get this party started
welcome to uncle joey's joint
[Music]
[Applause]
what's happening you bad [__]
happy valentine's day
half of you [__] will be
marching whatever getting drunk you're
probably [__] lit by now
you're filthy [__] and i don't
blame you i remember when i was younger
saint patty's day i went [__] i used
to go nuts
you start snorting david you start
snowing coke the day before
on st henry's day you know what i'm
saying so by the time patty comes around
you're ready for that [__]
thank you very much for enjoying the uh
theo vaughn podcast
listen man we're going to start zooming
once a week because this is just
listen i i love talking to you guys i
love i love letting you know what's in
my heart
but to be honest with you i've been
feeling a lot better since i've been
doing the zooms it took a lot of
pressure off me
plus i got to see my friends we've been
talking on the phone we've been just
talking you know i've been talking with
all these guys so
now when i see him in the zoom it's like
it brings a lot of emotion back to you
lets me know how much i love dio
i love that kid i love that kid with all
my heart and i'm happy he came
on and i'm i'm happy i kept in touch
with him and that's what we do you keep
in touch with your friends
the ones that matter some people don't
matter they tape it off you know
me i try to do my hardest when i see
somebody doesn't have interest
i lay off them but that's the rule
number one of the [__] joint
you got to give a [__] about your
friends and you got to check in with
them
not text them check in with them how you
doing what's going on
how's mom's doing and you know it's it's
a tough pandemic for [__] everybody i
was just telling mike
that my friend's dad died now let me
tell you something let me tell you the
type of guy i am i have known this guy
for three months three months so if you
want me to tell you he's a good friend
and lie to you and what
you know these people are you know my
mom
you don't even know the [__] person
so what are you so [__] you know
but he's such a great guy this guy mike
he's such a great guy
he's done me so much so many good things
as i've
moved here i call them the other they
check on him and he goes
joe i can't talk i'm with my father in
the [__] hospital you know i didn't
think about it then we have a mutual
friend
the guitar the guy who gives me guitar
lessons told me that his father
had coveted or whatever and uh well the
whole family got it
and you know just one of these [__]
horror [__] stories that you read
today
so i checked in with him every day you
know friday saturday
you know and then last night i got the
call that his father passed i didn't
want to bother him right off the bat
like you don't want to
jump on somebody right off the bat so i
just let him know that i was thinking
about him but i got to tell you
something guys while i was
doing it i got [__] teary-eyed
because it's like
when does this [__] end i don't even
know this [__] that well
it's not like he's one of my friends
from 40 years or 30 years or 20 years
but at one point your empathy starts to
[__] break you start looking at these
people
i got home before i had to do a thousand
[__] things this morning
i get home [__] 10 o'clock [__]
you know the computer
a kid carrying his mother in a [__]
casket i want to see that i need those
[__] memories in my life
but that's what's happening today so if
it's happening to you
i'm [__] sorry our hearts go out to
you
and your families man but back to this
[__]
listen guys when i told you the other
day i was [__] around heartbroken
about
j.lo and alex do you really think i'd
give a frenchman's [__]
it was a joke you dumb [__] i was just
[__] around
because most americans are at home going
oh my god
what are we going to do about j.lo and
alex what are you going to do she
ran through the [__] mill she's run
through the mill from rappers to roller
skaters
to ice dancers to dancers baseball
players
now everybody thinks canseco is [__]
with canseco new
she's going to run through this [__]
guy too can say goes over there now with
a swami thing reading bombs
like somebody gives a [__] about him go
put a [__] needle in your arm you got
that it's it's it's like you know these
[__] women
in l.a and it's tough to describe like
it's tough to describe you know
now everybody wants to cancel bill burr
the guy didn't even do nothing but
they set themselves up people these
[__] are setting themselves up
because it's like
why do you have them there you know he
hates the whole status quo
[__] you know there's a bunch of us that
hated that [__]
from day one myself joe rogan
bill burr that that that ain't for us
can you
listen when you if you if you're ever
sitting there
with your family during the academy or
the grammys
and you're like i wish i was there get
up and go
bang your head against the wall 10 times
you have no idea how bad those things
are
i know people who have gone in between
commercial breaks they got extras
sitting there and they have to get up
they don't let you get up
it's a [__] nightmare you see from
the bottom of the bar those event things
are [__] jokes
they're [__] jokes amongst us so if
you're gonna call bill bird to do one of
those things
bill burr's gonna [__] on it that's why
i love bill you can't take nothing from
us listen
you could only cancel us if we let you
cancel plus
that's it you could cancel us if we let
you cancel
like me they want to do that thing about
the girl 23 years ago you're in no
danger
you're in no [__] danger you're in no
danger about cancer nothing
if you're gonna cancel me you should
catch me about kidnapping the dude but
you didn't
you didn't give a [__] about a guy
handcuffed in that and in a trunk of a
car
with [__] uh handcuffs on
in there [__] like momo [__] no
you didn't care about him you cared
about some girl that nobody [__] knew
nobody knew but that's the world we live
in today and that's what we
so every comic most comics ninety
percent of comics are walking around
like what can i say well
you say whatever the [__] you want to
sing you let the pieces fall what the
[__] they
fall if they don't like it switch the
[__] channel
that's it it's that [__] simple i'm
not gonna say what i want to say from my
heart
because i'm scared that you're going to
cancel me go [__] yourself that ship
sailed
i canceled myself in [__] 19 in 2007
when i stopped snorting took
i canceled myself so you're in no
[__] danger but
it was nice talking to theo you know
listen man me and theo
have been going through something for
the last four or five years
me and theo always have deep deep
discussions about comedy and how it
should be
done or whatever and we both came to the
conclusion last week
before we did the podcast we were
talking on the phone like a week before
that
and i go now i know what was eating away
at you
and i it's that we were burnt out
number one number two we were living
amongst those [__] people we're
straight up people he's from new orleans
he's louisiana
from the south boy he's not into all
that [__]
hollywood [__] you think i'm into
the hollywood [__]
i know exactly who the [__] i am i'm a
felon they don't want me
i don't want them they don't want me
around them i don't want them around me
and they make believe like oh we love
you no you don't no you don't but i know
that going in
as long as you know it going in you're
not going to get your feelings hurt
you're not going to get upset you're not
going to get mad nothing's going to
happen to you bill burr
is handling everything he does a hundred
percent right he stuck up for gina
carano
which she had every right that we all do
because they fired her over [__]
nothing over some stupid [__] that they
were scared
she said the truth so what they're
trying to do now
is [__] if you say the truth if you
feel in your heart you're saying the
truth
say it who gives a [__] if they're gonna
can't see what they do
take away your little [__] john what are
they gonna do just don't be a [__]
jerk off about it
stand and commit it's so funny when you
first
get into comedy you write jokes and
sometimes
you're not ready for those jokes you
write a joke that and you say it and you
laugh and you go
[__] it's a funny joke but the audience
isn't getting it
because they could smell the
non-commitment
if you say a joke like hey yeah i'm
gonna [__]
they're not gonna be big say it be
yourself say it from your heart say it
from your soul so they know
when i'm on stage they know every
[__] word that's coming out of me is
[__] true
and they know i'm taking them for a
psychological ride you know i used to
have a bit about doing
coke with my cats jesus christ you don't
know how many times i had [__] people
reach out to me and go
do you really do coke with your cat it's
a joke it's a it's an
it's an exaggeration of a thing that's
what makes it funny
but do you think that's so convincing
i'm i'm surprised i'm not canceled over
that
because somebody actually wrote in my
wikipedia that i did coke with my cat
and that the cat died i mean
this is how [__] the land that we
live in so
if you want to cancel if you want to get
cancer you can let them cancel you i'm
not going nowhere bill burr is not going
nowhere
as you can see delia's attacking now
attack
brian callan i give him all the [__] and
i give him all the heart in the world
because
let's think let's talk about something
here that i wanted to talk to you people
about
just to let your head know where we came
from
there is no place on earth
like hollywood people will you've heard
that expression
sell their soul they will sell their
soul
male and female in hollywood
you change you
and here's a sad thing you don't know
when you're
in it you don't know when you're in it
for me it was 2004
i learned quickly i learned during the
taping of the longest yard
great movie great taping i had a great
time [__] doing it but
i also learned about smoke getting blown
up your ass
and how people in hollywood love to blow
smoke up your ass
and it was one of the first times that i
actually allowed somebody
i'm being honest with you guys i allowed
somebody a blow smoke up my ass i
actually believed it
i should be ashamed of myself for
[__] believing it
but that's what you get you get a smack
to the face when you believe it you
smack yourself in the [__] face
because you're a [__] idiot you don't
believe what these people tell you you
look at them you smile and you go
okay great after you're on a set you see
the [__] hypocrisy
and the [__] and you just work with
it
you laugh you smile you yeah sure right
whatever
lunch yeah have your people call my
people
you know that's all [__] that's all
[__] so
don't believe the [__] hype a couple
weeks ago this thing came on i don't
know a lot of you guys have hbo or not
so it's not fair for me to talk about
this but i'm going to tell you what
happened
hbo did a four part mini-series i think
it's a four-parter
on mia faro and [__] nut woody
allen okay
the thing was about accusations
accusations accusations accusations
i made a const a conscious decision
after the second week i looked at my
wife
after resolve and i go you know what
that's the last time i'm watching this
and my wife's like why and i go you know
why because we don't live in california
no more
and we're not part of hollywood no more
and this world
has nothing to do with me anymore
this is not who i am anymore this is not
who i want to be anymore
these are not the people i want to be
around anymore i made a constant [__]
decision a conscience
conscious decision july 12 last year
that i knew it was time for me to go
i have a gift that i know when it's time
to go no didn't they just
try to shoot didn't they just shoot a
lady and take a watch off some guy's
hand on
in beverly [__] hills and beverly
hills and it wasn't time to go
there's still people leaving in l.a
living in denial or waiting it out or
whatever the [__] they want to do
la ain't going to get no better and
ain't gonna get no better
this is called a down spot downward
spiral of california it's a [__]
shame
i love the place with all my heart you
know when you
when you're a jersey boy you grow up
thinking that someday i'm gonna go to
california
and just surf or whatever the [__]
stupid dream you have when you're a
[__] kid
you know that's why i'm glad you stopped
me from coming out there
like two years ago yeah you called me
one days like i'm thinking of coming out
here go
for what for what
i go we're almost done and i told you
that yes
i go i told you that we're almost done
it's just a matter of time sit tight
nothing's gonna happen here i already
was reading the cards
i was already done with la 2016.
i was pretty much done with l.a and i
was pretty much burnt out on comedy
the flight home from las vegas after the
netflix shooting
was the longest one hour of my life it
was i had to have the longest
talk in the world i have had a you know
i've had
a couple long talks with myself you have
to from time to time you know what i'm
saying
either you have to have a long talk with
yourself or you have to smack yourself
in the face
time to time okay i don't [__] around
the guys
every once in a while you gotta have to
[__] slap yourself or [__]
[__] what you do to friends oh you
know
this is why i don't lift my hands to
nobody because i don't i don't even i
can't
i can't even control them you know if
you're going to be that stupid just
smack yourself
and wake yourself the [__] up you know
but i i made a conscious decision i'm
gonna get the [__] out of here and i did
and i was very happy and that's all
behind this
but i'm gonna tell you before you
read any more about rapes alleges
accusations anything like that in l.a i
want you to
i don't know if you saw the the uh
the mia farrow versus woody whatever
but let me tell you what happened this
is what and when i said
this is it because this is what the
mentality is in l.a
just to let you guys know regular
americans
regular people overseas australia just
to let you know how pathetic these
people are
she found out woody
was molesting the kids whether or not
this is the accusation
she found out she was molesting the kid
while while she knew
and she approached him and she accused
him
she still worked on his movies
do you understand i'm trying to say to
you guys so wait a second so
joey diaz comes to my house rapes my kid
calls me up a week later or i don't know
what he did to him molested uh
grabbed him i don't know the accusation
i had to stop watching
all i do know is i know that he found
like
sunyi's picture naked pictures at his
house because
they kept different residences even
though they lived together
they kept separate apartments
so what you're telling me is that after
i let's just keep it simple here let's
just keep it simple so your head don't
blow up
you know because if you believe that i
gave a [__] about jlo and alex
god knows what you'll believe i didn't
know i was that good of an actor
let's pretend i molested my little
brother mike's kid here
i don't think mike would work for me no
more i think mike would call the cops
and i wouldn't blame him he's not a rat
he's just
protecting his child and other children
from getting molested from a guerrilla
like me
yeah i don't think mike
would take a call from me and go i'll be
up there monday to do a podcast for you
i forgave you about molesting my child
because that's unforgivable where i live
as a matter of fact
where i come from not north bergen
not new jersey but where i come from
that's an act of i could shoot you in
the [__] head and call the cops
and tell the cops i don't know what
happened he molested my child and the
cops are okay we'll drop them off in the
weeds for you
thank you for getting the molester off
the [__] streets
but now we live in different times you
can't be doing that [__]
she sold her soul yeah she sold her soul
but it's not just me a pharaoh you hear
these stories
constantly so you rape me and then
when brian called you you actually went
to the audition
to play his wife come again do you
understand me
so this is what runs through
this is the mentality of hollywood
they don't give a [__] it's like the
people who went to work for woody
harrison listen
i'm not mad at you you you got monster
is that his name woody allen
harrison yeah whatever uh the people
that went to work from like a lot of
people who
work from in films they get heat for
working from you know what i'm saying i
don't
i don't judge nobody for working from i
don't pay your bills so
until i pay your bills like a judge what
the [__] you saying even then
but they work for him because they need
the money you know
knowing that he's a [__] child
molester or whatever he's been falsely
accused or properly accused or whatever
you know so think about what people will
do
in hollywood that's just the mindset of
hollywood when i watch mia pharaoh speak
who i've always been a fan of you know i
loved her in rosemary's baby
um she reminded me
of every actress i spoke to in l.a
like they all have that common thing you
know i'm saying like they'll do certain
things but
it was very sad to me you know and i
just told my wife i'm not watching this
no more because
i like i told my wife if you found out
i'm molested [__] mercy would you
work for me as a
if i directed movies she looked at me
and said you'd be in jail
you know that that's not here or there
but that's just to let you know the
mentality
of where i came from you know i it never
got to me like
that i i tell you to go [__] yourself
and i did
and once i got off the cocaine
that's when i really saw hollywood for
what it was and after that
people didn't listen at the longest shot
people didn't really want to work for me
i'm not i'm not ashamed to tell you i
love adam adam loves me but he had a
producer
who didn't like me because he came up
there he wanted me to do something i
told him to go [__] himself
told him right to his face i don't give
a [__] i was looking for a job when i
found this one
you talk to me like a man and don't
[__] talk to me at all until this day
me and that producer don't get along he
retired he quit he's moved on he's a
gazillionaire
you know uh he was a good producer i'm
not here to say he was a bad producer i
think
he just approached me a way that i don't
like i told him what i felt
that's why sometimes you see a poster
along his yard and i'm on it
and then you see another post and i'm
not on it that was all his doing
to break my balls at the end he put me
the last and the thing
he did everything he could to break me
but at the end i kicked ass in that
[__] movie he did everything he could
he did everything he could to to try to
die everything
you don't understand how i still
remember the day i had to shoot the
scene with the [__] in the locker
room with the thong on
with my stomach hanging out that was my
[__] idea
that was my [__] idea because i
wanted it i wanted
out of respect for serrano a major
league if you ever see the cuban guy in
major league
when the owner of the club comes in
she's he's got a thong on and she smacks
him in the ass
i'm not saying that some hot chicks
gonna smack me in the ass
but out of respect for serrano i thought
it would have been a funny scene
if i just wore a jock strap or whatever
there were these two [__]
you know white little college kids from
paramount or whoever company is talking
to adam
when i went up to adam i said excuse me
like a gentleman i had the jock strap
already in my hand i go at him i want to
wear a jock strap in this scene
and he says to me and the two dudes are
talking to adam
and they're like don't let them do it
adam and adam was like whoa whoa
what do you want to do you ever see
major league i want to wear like serrano
did i want to wear a [__]
bro he's like let's give it a [__] go
see
right away the producer's like no he's
not doing it adam said let him try it
let's see how it looks when i bro and
you know me
they were like what are you gonna do
right here in the thing i go just put a
towel up you see when the fighters go to
weigh themselves they put a towel up
there was chicks in the room they were
[__] line directors
the chick from scripty that [__] were
dying to take your mind i said i don't
give a frenchman's [__]
adam didn't give a [__] about my balls
one day they fell out of my shorts like
i was sitting there and
i was sitting on a bucket and my balls
fell out of my shorts
and people were talking about me i
didn't even know it like i was high i'm
looking around
because new mexico is gorgeous i'm just
looking around at the scenery
and all of a sudden adam sandler walks
up to me right here the corner of my eye
and he goes joey i don't mean to insult
you but your little
your punching bag is hanging out so he
would call my one nut the punching bag
so that's how it started so after that
he's like dawg
how big are your [__] balls that's
just one of them
jesus christ he goes i didn't know
people's walls could even be so [__]
big
but no i said listen
i don't even know how we got on this
subject i'm sorry
yeah kyle you know accusations for
people that lost their souls yeah
all these [__] people in la so i had
to unwind from that you could tell
i'm a lot better dude i'm doing a lot
better
than when you first saw me and i was
like this [__] mummified in front of
here
i'm a little bit more loose you know
things are happening
because i was beat up those last four
years were [__]
torture torture the more you think about
it after i talked to theo
not on the podcast but before that i
understood what was going on and i
understood what was going on with him
and i understood what was going on with
me so us two
just psychologically [__] worked it
out
and we figured it out and it was great
seeing him on that screen
and i mean that night after we did the
podcast we spoke again
about what we spoke about in the podcast
you know the fun we had
you know listen man i'm i'm very proud
about a lot of things i'm very proud
that i did 880 episodes of the church
i'm also very proud i ended it and
started something new
and you guys are now witnessing the
growth as we do it
some people couldn't take it after two
episodes and they left and that's fine
i'm not mad at them
to each his own i think the first six
episodes of this podcast were [__]
all over the place it's been the last
maybe month
month and a half that we've been on pace
and getting a grasp
so i thank you for sticking around and
thank you for understanding the process
it takes to have a [__] podcast and
to do a podcast you know
everybody always criticizes this one or
that one
i heard something the other day that was
[__] hilarious
a friend of mine sent me a video it was
on youtube and he goes i want you to
hear these two [__] jerk-off comics
see the prom see when you guys didn't
know what was going on was that
and leo tell you lee will tell you
because lee
and i talked about it all the time the
routing was
they would call joe rogan first and if
they couldn't get through the rogan
they'd hit me up at the same time
so if rogan raised their hand then they
would blow me off
you know i'm saying so if i would say
you want to come on the podcast
and rogan would say no then they would
come in like [__] happy as [__] you
know i'm saying
listen here's the problem with the
podcast that everybody got confused with
i did when rogan started his podcast
let's say 2010 to be conservative
2009. let's just go with 2009.
liquid [__] debt it's just sparkling
water tremendous
i think there's a website for it check
it out uh my girl sent it to me from
nebraska colleen i love it with all my
art
i told i try it it's [__] tremendous
like a carbonated water
in the [__] 80s when you went on
johnny carson for you guys who watch the
documentary or maybe you don't know how
comedy works
when you go on something you immediately
blow up
what does that mean joey we don't know
what that means well
when roseanne was at the store
mitzi saw her in the original room and
she liked it so much she told her to go
up in the main room
and then while she was up on stage in
the main room
two people from the tonight shows saw
some one person i don't know the exact
story
if i'm backing the story up let me know
i'm just trying my [__] best
and they put on the tonight show
once they put you on the tonight show if
you killed
and johnny carson went like this to you
you just became a half a millionaire
you just got a half a million dollars
worth of work
you're gonna they're gonna put you in
two films and every comedy club in the
country is gonna watch it
that's just by johnny carson going like
this okay
johnny carson went off the air then it
was um
the the show that was on comedy central
with the guys great [__] show patrice
rich vos
tough crowd it was tough crowd if you
went on tough crowd you blew up then it
was opie and anthony
you know people were dying to get on
opening anthony that was howard stern
but then it was a reputation of [__]
joe rogan
that if you went on joe rogan you blew
up
yes and no did it bother a guy like me
that people would say something like
that that would be so shallow
yeah because the first time i went on
rogan i was already doing comedy 18
years i had already done
five or six [__] major films i was a
regular at the store
i was kind of co-headlining already
i was starting to headline and
co-headline i was not a headliner
i'm not going to tell you that but i was
headlining
big difference in being a headliner and
being a comedian that's headlining
i wasn't a headliner it took me a couple
years to learn
thank god rest in peace greg geraldo
taught me what a real headliner was when
i watched him
uh for a long time i just you know
ralphie may was a true headliner joe
rogan is a true headliner
bill burr off the charts headliner i was
a comic
i was what's considered a comics comic
i perform for the back of the room
there's no money in the back of the room
it's comics comics aren't going to pay
you
so that's what i was i was considered a
comics comic
that's when you perform for the back of
the room so for years
i didn't give a [__] about the audience
i hadn't made the comics left
that's and that's great too that's a
great thing to have too when you're a
comics comic
that's a very good reputation to have
but you're not really a real [__]
full-blown national touring headliner
there's two and i understood that at the
time in 2000
8009 2008
i said i'm gonna take six months
and every thursday night i'm gonna drive
to the irvine improv and see who the
headliner is
and the first thursday i drove down it
was greg corral though
i did not know i did not i knew he was
from new york i knew he had a tv show
i watched greg geraldo i watched patrice
o'neill even though i was headlining
i wanted to become a headliner
i watched all that joe rogan was always
a [__] headline that [__]
always had a tight one
a tight hour and it was a tight hour it
was
a hung and it was weave i was just out
there throwing stuff
anyway the purpose of this is for me to
tell you that
when i went on rogan i never i'll tell
you some secrets
i'll tell you some secrets that happened
later but when i went on rogan
the first two or three years i didn't
know what was going on
i just went on there with the impression
to be funny i went on there to do
what i love doing the best making my
friend
laugh i love making and laugh there's
certain people when you make them laugh
it brings a warmth to your heart when i
would make that man laugh
it would [__] warm my heart so much
because
i knew how hard it was to make him laugh
and for him to go crazy and i knew and i
know the [__]
that he likes for me to say like i know
that
when there's a room full of people he
wants me to go into one of my tirades he
fuels that [__] that's why joe rogan is
one of the best
adam sandler's one of the best because
they don't put a thumb
on you they want you to be funny i'm the
same way
when i tell my features go out there and
[__] them up make it hard for me i don't
give a [__]
go out there and [__] him up kate
dean carmen morales chelsea skidmore all
of them i told them all
go out there and [__] them up don't
worry about me
because when i was opening up for rogan
he would pull me aside
and go dog get your [__] together
go out there and [__] them up and i
would look at them and go okay
and i would smack myself i get my shits
four left
that's four [__] rights to the
[__] right side in one day
when i [__] up i beat myself up enough
enough it's time to stop beating
yourself
up [__] that's it i would go
i would get fired up and i would go out
there and listen
i was such a bad comic at the time like
i was a good comic
but i was a 50 50 comic i couldn't
control my destiny i didn't know
what direction i could go in so all that
being said
i heard this [__] little chat between
two jerk off comics
and it was about that one of them is
going to austin and he didn't get
invited on rogan's podcast
and that he heard that the last time his
friend did it
nothing really happened well and that
when the other guy did it nothing really
happened well
you went on there and you weren't funny
that's what happened you went on there
and tried to be a smart guy with rogan
and you weren't funny when i went on
rogan's part then
i i after i found out all this [__]
people come up thinking oh you're so
lucky
you get to go on rogue whenever you want
i go no i don't
no i don't ask joe i have certain dates
the last podcast of the year
and fourth of july if you check all his
podcasts
check i always did them in july
and the last one of the year there was a
reason for that
there was a reason for that and every
time i went on there
i had i prepared myself from that
[__] morning
to the time i got there because i knew i
was going on and i wasn't gonna [__]
around
that was my secret now people would go
to me why don't you go on there a lot
more you should go on there a lot more
because i'm not a stupid hall like you i
go on twice a year
and my [__] chances of killing are
even stronger
if i go eight times a year i'm gonna
bomb two or three times
it's the [__] number it's a magic
number but twice
my chances are bombing yeah some
podcasts were better than others
but i always left my soul on the table
on the rogan podcast
the same way i did on my table the same
way i did on ryan cycles table
the same way i did on stage these
[__] want to go
date and you saw it when you were there
people contacted me to go on my podcast
or rogan's podcast
because they thought it would change
their life like this
guess what nothing changes your life
like this and even if it does
if you're not prepared for it what good
is it
what good is it you got to be prepared
for what's coming at you
just because you want it doesn't mean
you're prepared for it did you ever
think about that
just because you want it doesn't mean
you're prepared for it
and how do i know this because i saw
this
not a hundred times close to 500 times
i saw 500 comics come to la
to [__] steal hollywood off his feet
and guess what happened
[__] that's what happened they didn't
put in the time
they went their reputations they would
take a shortcut they'd go to montreal
they would get on new faces get a deal
and then they'd make a mistake they'd
show up to the and then
everybody wants to see them when they
get back to la they start doing
showcases
but one of those nights you pop into the
improv and you got to follow a savage
like bill burr
[__] doug stan hope rogan myself some
what happens to you what happens to you
you don't know how many times
i had people coming up to me at the
improv going dog can you switch with the
guy in front of you
because he's got industry coming to see
him
and he doesn't want you to disrupt their
set like [__] like that and i
and i understood i'm going to be honest
here i understood
but at the same time i felt bad for them
because if some young people came to see
me in 23 years
maybe 10. these [__] had people
coming to see them every night
but when people came to see me i [__]
blew up that room
i didn't give a [__] who was in front of
me i didn't give a [__] who was behind
me
i didn't let none of that enter my mind
because that's when you fail
you know that's when you [__] fail
that's what and then
you know a lot of comics they know that
you have a showcase
and they'll get like at this comedy
store if you had a showcase for somebody
they would put an asterisk next to your
name
and that let the other comics know you
didn't have a paid spot
that you had a [__] showcase
so what would they do anytime you were
talking to somebody they would come up
over and say hello and hug you like they
really cared about you so i would
introduce them to the [__] agent
that's what they do that's what they do
in california so i had to tell people
don't put a star next to me when people
want to come see me
because then there were comics that
didn't get stage time
and would call and say i have a showcase
for a certain company can you put me up
there was a certain guy that was doing
that all the time he got [__] nailed
because they told him one night where's
fox come produce him
go get him or you're not going up and
he's like i don't know what happened to
them
you're not going up but i have a 9 15
spot too bad
you're not [__] going up it's that
[__] simple sorry charlie
the best tasting tuna gets to be
starkids you know i'm saying
it's that [__] easy
but it's just crazy that
an experienced comic would think that
one appearance
on the joe rogan show would change their
[__] life forever
that's so between that mentality
and the mere pharaoh mentality next time
you hear
about accusations or this or that
think about what i just told you the
people that
think that one thing is going to change
their [__] life because that exists
out there
listen i knew tiffany haddish when she
was babysitting i congratulate her for
her grammy
you know i go back and forth from time
to time i check up on her
i still remember having a conversation
outside the the laugh factory with her
with ralphie
and her telling us about her growing up
and whatever i loved that girl i give
her all the respect
in the [__] world but look at her
blow up who knew
she was going to be a movie girls night
right girls night four women
for african-american women girl that
girl was busting her ass for [__]
years
she used to go on the road with red band
her red banner dear friends
you know when she blew up people felt
[__] calling me like
she's not worthy who the [__] are you to
say she's not about people attacked
her to the end i'm so happy she won the
[__] grammy
i'm sad she beat bill burr bill burr
lost to grammy but
he knew that going in after you insult
the spanish people and
the guy's piano solo and that's true
listen
you ever go to one of those things that
you know the other night i was watching
the blue the green
the green book the green book won the
academy award two years ago
nick vaughn along with the story of his
father
and i'm watching these [__] fancy
people you know
you ever see those people they're all
fancy and dressed up and they're
clapping for some piano playing violin
and you're sitting there going oh i
don't get it
i don't get this what what's all this
[__] what's all this glam and fake [__]
for
like you would really go pay to see some
guy like
pay a [__] ball like i i don't
[__] see it
and in the movie if you walk because i
watched the movie the other night it was
a very great movie
he tells the guy the guy that's the same
guy
the guy that's the star in that movie
the african-american dude that's whose
head was starting to get square
the night i took the ketamine that's the
same guy from the green book that's why
i always felt bad when i watched the
green book i'm like i felt bad that his
head
was tripping out that night i was
tripping out on his [__] head but
there's a part in that way the
african-american tells
uh veto morgan's and he goes we have to
talk about your last name we have to
change it
it's too long people might not be able
to say it
uh and you know there and he tells them
how smart they are and he he tells them
he has to watch his diction the way he
speaks and he goes what are you talking
about diction
i speak great you know and he goes no
you curse too much
and you [__] they can't he goes all
right i'll tame down on my cursing
but then he goes another thing we have
to worry about your name
he goes these are cultured people
they're intelligent and all this [__]
you can't be talking that way
but on the other side he's telling him
that he had to change his name
because people wouldn't be able to say
it he told him right now you watch that
movie mike
he told him around he goes if they were
so [__] smart
they could say my name right if they're
so [__] smart and so cultured
like how culture is that what it means
to be cultured to sit there with a
[__] tuxedo on
to watch a three-piece band and do
whatever
you know listen i appreciate the
instruments i i appreciate the work
you put into to playing the piano i
appreciate the work you put in
we had the violinist on the show who did
a great job eliza i love it at that
you know i appreciate all that [__] but
i don't appreciate [__] people
getting dressed up
with tuxedos whatever with the wife
looking like she's going to a [__]
wedding
and you sit there and make believe
like you're enjoying this nobody could
enjoy this that's torture
that [__] piano at the end what do
you say cause i didn't watch the grammys
i knew it was on
it [__] interrupted my queen latifah
they almost killed themselves
yeah it interrupted my [__] uh
equalizer
because i watched 60 minutes every week
i'm a 60 minute type of [__]
so it interrupted my [__] you know i
saw what was coming on 60 minutes got
off
so it interrupted my [__] equalizer
and it [__] uh you know
i didn't watch it at all i don't know
presentation wasn't on tv
either he said i bought a suit i thought
this was gonna be on tv yeah
who the [__] knows i would have told
them no off the bat i want to be down
there with those people
puking and whatever but at the same time
like
i i wasn't gonna watch it i just gave up
on grammys and oscars it just
if ricky gervais was hosting i would
have watched
the monologue just to see him go off and
make people uncomfortable
again even ricky gervais every year they
make him the host
and every year you know that whoever
hires him has got to be giggling in the
back
because he loves seeing people get
uncomfortable the same thing the same
reason why why would you
hire bill burr a guy that you know
doesn't give a [__] about what the [__]
you're doing here
he don't give a [__] about the grammys
none of us do
no why would you hire one of us why
would it's like hiring
joe rogan he's gonna go up there and
tell him to [__] off i'm not doing this
[__] none of us want to do that [__]
so when you do hire a guy like bill burr
you know what you get yourself into
i would think you know you [__] know
he's gonna go up there with his [__]
you know boston attitude i loved it
well i didn't see the grammys but i saw
the next day people attacking them
and right away they're yelling for
cancer culture now you're looking to
cancel fluffy
for the voice of speedy gonzales i
thought that was fake but
yeah but then the song of the year was
wet my [__]
or something like that so we got
we got a pic you [__] gotta
[__] pick get your [__] together
you really [__] do this is getting
old now guys
you know and see the book what most
people don't understand like most people
are living in fear from this i know a
ton of comments are like you know what
[__] you i'm saying what the [__] i want
to say
i'm doing what the [__] i want to do and
i'm saying it how i want to right now
listen i got three shows left at uncle
vinnie's
i'm gonna take some time for myself and
the family for the summer
get my head together you know fall in
love with comedy again
i did write a little half a bit
yesterday
yeah i'm just thinking about something i
wrote it down so i got a couple new
things i'm going to try
what happened last week was i went to a
[__] christening
party before uncle vinnie's and i wasn't
focused
i didn't laser i didn't even look at my
notebook i thought i would remember
everything so i went down there and ate
a bag of dicks
at least i'm mad enough man enough to
admit it
a lot of guys would say i killed no you
didn't you know i'm the type of guy that
tells you how it is
that night i came home i i taped my set
but i already knew already there was
nothing to listen to
because i didn't even try out nothing
new i was just up there going through
old [__] just trying to [__] find
myself or whatever
but this week i'm a little bit more
ready i got three more sets
in for the month three more wednesdays
and after that i'll take a breather
man when i come back because you figure
the soprano movie comes out september
24th i'll start itching like in august
because i've been in the house for a
year and a [__] half by that time
so just give it time before you could
[__] successfully do something you
want to love it you don't want to feel
like you're forcing it
that sucks have you ever tried to force
anything
it sucks whether it's making believe you
into something it just it just sucks and
sometimes we do it
we do it we do it you know and that's
why people end up sick
that's why people end up fat that's why
people end up
because it makes you unhappy you know
they have a thing in this country where
they force your hand
at the age of 19 to pick a major in
college
and then you pick that major and
you graduate and you go out into the job
market and you figure out that
this is not even close to what i wanted
to do
you know what about these guys well my
father was this
i'm gonna be this and then two years in
you're realizing you don't do it you
don't like doing it but you're doing it
for somebody else
you're gonna end up sick you're gonna
end up [__] depressed
you're gonna end up miserable you're
gonna end up doing something you don't
want to do
one thing about me is i'm a loser by
trade i'm a loser
i've come to that conclusion a long time
ago but guess what
i don't do whatever the [__] i don't
want to do i never
have that's the problem i have that's
what makes me a loser
that i don't do what i don't want to do
i don't want to do it i just don't do it
that's it and that's the way it's going
to be
for me to do something i want to do it
from the core of my balls
when i come in here at night and i
practice on that guitar
you know when i first started when mike
gave me the guitar i was going through
videos on youtube
and that's how i knew that i couldn't
learn online
because i had gone through a few videos
and
videos were it was just hard for me to
learn from videos i
my mind wasn't into it or whatever thank
you for all the people who are offering
guitar lessons and videos
i love you [__] and in time
when this thing clears up
we will do some we will have some
[__] fun we will
do some things that are different you
know maybe on patreon we can do a guitar
thing i don't know but we'll burn that
bridge
when we get through it but the one thing
i did pick up
from all those videos i watch and i got
to tell you something my watch close to
without exaggeration maybe 50 videos on
the guitar
basic guitar stuff i picked one thing up
i picked one thing up and i love that
guy i don't know he's a goofy looking
dude
he's got glasses i wrote his name down
so i could
watch the rest of his stuff as i
progress
because i liked what he had to say this
was a video about
being older and picking up the guitar
not being a young kid and picking up the
guitar this is for people that he goes
when i was teaching people the guitar
every once in a while somebody would
come in that was way older than me and
i'd have to teach him
and i'd have to change up my style you
know to teach a 50 year old or a 60 year
old
a 40 year old he goes because i just
worked with kids
but he said something that was very
interesting that i've always believed it
he goes make a goal you ready for this
one again we're talking about goals
make a goal that you're going to play
the guitar
five minutes a day that's it he goes and
i don't want you to put your guitar in
your case
i want you to buy a stand for your
guitar it's very important that you have
a stand
and he goes because
if you tell you if you're beginning he
goes i don't want you to practice more
than five minutes
i want you to touch that guitar every
day for five minutes because i know
that you'll improve a lot better if you
play that guitar
five minutes a day than 30 minutes
one day i listened to what he said i'm
like jesus christ
that is brilliant and and guess what
else he said he goes
and it also teaches you that
you're not going to play the guitar for
five minutes you're gonna play it for
30.
let you pick it up but your goal for the
day
is to pick it up for five [__]
minutes
that's it so basically it's just take it
off pick it up
pick it up strap it on play three chords
and put it down he goes i rather you do
that
than not pick it up at all and guess
what i do every night now
my life is changed here at the house
listen
i'm like you i can't watch no more
[__] tv
if i got to watch one more [__] tv
nobody has made more residuals than
stovetop stallone dave played every
single
stallone movie he's ever made in his
life there's nights where he has four
movies
on at once i love sylvester stallone but
i had to give him a break
i saw the first rambo 20 times during
this pandemic
i've seen rambo two 80 times trust me my
dick still gets hard
when he shoots the the vietnamese do
with the arrow when he blows up i love
all that type of [__]
i have seen you know the other night
lockdown was on it was so funny
the next day a guy on patreon asked me
have you ever seen the movie locked down
yeah cause he saw it i'm like oh my god
it was on last night it's about him he
goes to prison
and they fix a car whatever nobody has
made more money than sylvester stallone
over the top the wrestling one
cliffhanger i watched the other night at
[__] eight o'clock you know you you
could just watch so much tv
guys you just start getting soft and
during the pandemic even with my [__]
thing i would do sit-ups at night i got
i said all right i'll start doing 100
[__] you know put my knee up and just
do sit-ups and
then i started reading thank god i'm
reading
now i gotta pick another book cause i
finished the book i was reading
so i gotta pick another book that i've
read already and i was looking at it
last night i couldn't come to a
conclusion
i think i'm gonna read the pleasant
avenue connection just
uh because i'm trying to get my
comprehension i'm trying to get focused
again my focus
is all over the place but
on top of the reading the [__] guitar
has moved me from point
let's say in in the alphabet from
z is the worst that your mental state
could be
and a is the best that your mental state
was
when i got the guitar i was probably at
q
and now i'm probably at [__] g
i'm getting closer to my world guys i'm
getting closer to my world every day and
listen yeah
there was fear involved there was the
anxiety of the move
there was the anxiety of whether my
daughter my wife would like it
there was the anxiety of the career
there was the anxiety of the podcast
there was all these different anxiety
that just met and [__] me up
completely
and i'm not you know i'm not ashamed to
admit the [__] truth
that i go see a therapist not really
because
it's against what i believe but i use my
friends
i used all my friends and i ran my ideas
by them
and i rap with them and anytime a friend
wanted to see me
and the weather was nice i [__] run
to his house and i'd sit in the backyard
with him
and even though he was eating me alive
inside that i might get this covered and
die
look we're still [__] here knock on
wood every [__] day
you know i've gotten through this and
it's been hard
but the mo the happiest thing the thing
that makes me the happiest
is that you guys have seen it i'm just
not telling you
a story from 10 years ago you know 10
years from now i won't be saying i was a
mess
no i've been telling you guys that we've
been going through this
but i'm not i've been doing good i'm not
doing well i'm doing better
i'm doing better thanks to you guys the
patreon the videos
the little [__] around now the
instagram now the guitar
i'm almost there i'm at g and i hope you
guys
are at g2 everything helps i've cleaned
up my diet i've
you know the pain pills are gone the
knee still hurts i get frustrated but
what am i gonna do it's only two and a
half months i'm home
i got two more weeks and i'm out of the
[__] weeds
but the point i wanted to make is that
um listen man
i don't know what condition you're in
what mental condition you're in
how you're doing you know there's a
light
we're seeing this light so whatever
you're going through now is the time to
start getting ready remember we kept
saying
this is all going to be over soon this
is all going to be over soon this is all
going to be over soon
it ain't going to be over yet we still
got a little bit to go but
there is a light at the end of the
tunnel you know last thursday i got a
call that somewhere i was at
had [__] covered somebody that tested
positive for covert
i took the instant test on friday i took
another
test uh it wasn't the rapid test this is
the one where you work for the email
i went down there friday and took
another one he told me because if you
got it
it won't it's not going to go in your
system if you had contact with that
person
on a certain night i had contact with
that person on a tuesday night
i got the call on thursday so he goes
give it like five days
so you know i don't want to give it to
mike i don't want to give it to somebody
at vinnie's
so i went again yesterday and i got the
result this morning uh
that were [__] negative so i feel a
lot better but i'm i'm i was tripping on
this
and like i said in time we'll get the
vaccine
right now let it roll out let people do
what we're doing i'm not doing much
it's not like i'm going to concerts
right now it's not like i'm doing comedy
shows or anything
i'm doing one show a week to 41 people
and uh you know we use all the
precautions we can and
i gargle i got the nose spray you know
the no steroid i use
that would used to be 36 a container
and now it's 200 a container and they
make me pay for it because
it's anti-covet spray so at the same
time it's a no steroid
it's also like anti-covered something it
went up it shot up because people are
using it
to avoid whatever it's my regular nose
bruh i've been using it
since 2013 since i got the [__] nose
job
once a month you go through that i go i
go through two bottles a month
and they raise the [__] prices up but
that's that's the medical system
when i was in high school well that's
how i got the [__] surgery i was
hooked on afrin
i was hooked on afrin since my cocaine
[__] days
and then i started jiu jitsu and i
couldn't breathe out of my [__] nose
unless i brought afro i just found an
afrin
i was looking through one of my [__]
sports bags
because we open listen i the reason why
i haven't opened up i'm very
sorry to a lot of you people i love you
guys to that
and i know you guys like to send stuff
and you offer stuff to me
it's not that i don't want it we got two
sheds out there
one we had to take down to put the
generator in we gave it to my man frank
puma across the street
and the other shed is filled to the brim
with boxes from the move once i get
those [__] boxes cleaned up
then i'll put my p.o box out there you
can send me whatever the [__] you want
to send me
i'll take whatever you got shoes weights
[__] you know when i left la i gave
away so much stuff
that i never got to enjoy because i
didn't even know half the [__] existed
i was just finding i would come back
from the road people would give me
pictures look mike brook two pictures
over here the other day
two great [__] pictures that somebody
sent them a year ago and he forgot to
come see me at parks or something
happened i don't know
guys i got a a storage shed filled with
boxes
let me empty these [__] boxes and see
what i got in this [__]
and then you could start sending me my
stuff i'll put it on the podcast for you
whatever the [__] you want to do
but let me just clean out these [__]
sheds i don't want to get another p.o
box
every time i would go to the p.o box it
would be a car load
on the way back the trunk
the trunk would be [__] in a subaru
sitting there
tremendous [__] people sent me the best
[__] in the [__] world
protein shakes this everybody you know
listen man everybody's trying to promote
their stuff and i appreciate it
you know i got a lot of sh i got a lot
of stuff that was junk too
don't get me wrong wallet clips and [__]
that was just garbage
but i like the stuff people make with
their hands that's the stuff i never got
rid of like like this right here
my future brother-in-law steve i loved
when people drew pictures of me
and people would come in and go that is
the ugliest joe diaz i've ever said and
i go i don't give a [__]
somebody put time into that somebody sat
down
and put time into that i'll put a frame
on it
and then sell it i'll do something but
i'm not just going to throw it away
somebody put time into that
i wish i could draw half as good
as some of these people that have sent
me heart i wish i could draw half as
well as them
that's a [__] gift all to itself but
hey we get what they give us
to me they gave me the gift of gab and
big balls i got no looks
and a medium dick but i got big balls
and they gift a gap we all can't get the
same [__]
i can't change a light bulb i'm half
polish i can't [__]
uh change oil you know i can't do
nothing it's hysterical because
i swear to god i must have been on the
podcast
and some guy on patreon who's a
sweetheart we had tons of conversations
before that
he [__] went off on me you have to
take the pan
the [__] uh the whatever the [__] the
vaccine
at that time in the beginning a month
ago i was a little unsure
i wanted for them to roll it out to see
what the [__] results were going to
be
going in order plus they're going in
[__] order you know
you know people he's like well you have
a celebrity status no i'm not a [__]
celebrity
i'm a suburban house dad i'm a suburban
house that
first of all i was never a [__]
celebrity i was a dirty comic that got
lucky
so i don't know why you keep using that
word celebrity you never see me at
celebrity golf tournaments or celebrity
bowling tournaments
celebrity nothing because i'm not a
[__] celebrity and i don't want to be
a [__] celebrity
i'm a [__] dirty comic i got lucky
from time to time people put me in their
[__] movies
that's it well you're a celebrity you
should [__] go down there and get i
said listen stop right there
i go first door and you know he was
telling me he was polish but
that's how a conversation grew because i
like pierogies
i like stuffed [__] green peppers
i like polish food yeah actually you
call it [__] it's it's
it's stuffed [__] peppers you guys
got the correct
enunciation i'm [__] i just call it
gunky
so uh he says to me you gotta get he
kind of like went off and away
and i was like i can't [__] believe i
got the only pollock who could put a
light bulb in
telling me that i need a [__] vaccine
20 million polocks
and i got the only one that got screwing
a light bulb yelling at me
for [__] i don't i think he
unfollowed me i think he left i think he
got pissed off
yeah but we were friends you know like
we were [__] on there [__] around
so
if he did get upset i'm sorry i didn't
mean it like that you know
i i respected polox all my life because
they're the only ones that never bitched
throughout this whole thing
right everybody makes fun of black
people it makes fun of chinese people
they get pissed
spanish people get pissed you've never
seen a parade outside of barnes and
noble
with people going take the polish books
down you know 100 polish books how to
change a light bulb
they've been writing [__] polish
jokes since the beginning of time
and these people do not give a [__] this
has not been one protest
there hasn't been a parade because they
don't give a [__] they're too busy
eating pierogies
and drinking vodka you go to a polish
[__] wedding
that's four [__] days you never been
to a polish wedding oh
oh you don't know what life is until you
go to a polish wedding in buffalo
it's six [__] days it's six or seven
days
they're eating drinking dancing i forget
the dance they do with the [__]
dresses
forget about it when you want to go to a
real party you go party with the polox
they don't [__] around jack
they do not [__] around polish weddings
are
sensational if you're into that stuff
i'm into fun
like greek i don't want to yeah i don't
want to go to a wedding and sit there
and everybody bang a glass and she
kisses
and i can't curse in front of the old
[__] grandmother
because they're going to die and the six
flower mage or a bunch of [__] anyway
i don't like those weddings those
weddings you don't don't even invite me
to those [__] things
but if you're going to have a fun
wedding you know jump and [__]
firecrackers and
people get bought you know draw hammered
and nobody cares nobody's going to be
judgmental towards you
and if you want to take your vest off
and dance with your [__]
shirt you know those are the weddings i
like those uptight [__] weddings
save them for somebody the [__] else i'm
sorry
yeah i'm so upset because i was looking
forward to going to j lo's and alex
wedding
i was looking forward to going to that
puerto rican [__] wedding
like i was gonna get invited get the
[__] out of here you cuban [__]
puerto rican weddings are fun too but i
didn't give a [__] about jlo
i don't give a frenchman's [__] about
alex rodriguez i mean i loved him as a
baseball player
i didn't get mad at him about the
steroids what are you going to do people
are going to do what they're going to do
but uh yeah i guess they're not going to
get married now so
i can't believe i'm gonna miss that
wedding you know i won't be able to sit
next to kim
you know the [__] out of here what do i
give a [__]
anyway we had a great week we had a
great time
uh that's it
it's just another fun [__] podcast
another week is gone
it's march 17th the saint patty's day
go out there march drink have a good
time just don't get cold i don't give a
[__] what you do
i mean last name patty's day got [__]
uh
[__] cancelled so i guess this one
i'm gonna be smoking
puffin eating i haven't eaten an edible
in the daytime
and so [__] long
since that day with the spray with you
tomorrow's the day
tomorrow might be the [__] day
i can't stop on my way you know what i
can't even [__] do an edible
daytime no more my responsibilities are
so [__] high now it's not like l.a
where
let's take it at 159 then it'll be two
and you'll be fine
now i'm not gonna take another ball
happy saint patty's day to all you
[__] i love you thank you very
much for watching
thank you very much for understanding
what we were talking about but again
today's podcast was basically about
[__] when i saw that mia farrow
and whatever thing so before you believe
any more accusations
or any more stupidity that comes out of
la and the hollywood scene
remember what i told you mia faro
continued working for woody allen
after she knew that he was molesting her
children
and that's what hollywood is all about
so
i'm happy to be out of that scene i'm
happy i don't live in that anymore
and i'm happy i'm not in that
entanglement of [__] anymore
i'm in new jersey now [__] the other
day i went to eat with my wife
uh sunday
these two parents called us up and they
said do you want to meet at the park
we're going to play some baseball
it was a kind of nice day so i went over
there with mercy and my wife and
mercy had the glove i had to break in
because mercy starts softball next week
thank god so she's doing this saturday
we're taking her for a mini camp
like me and a friend of mine because my
wife was supposed to get a [__]
covert shot on friday
but now they call it there might be a
problem so i already made plans for
saturday to take us i'm like you know
because the second shot is a little
[__] tougher
so i made plans just a buddy of mine
from north bergen is coming down
he uh played professional baseball he
got drafted so
we're gonna take it to the batting cages
and just you know i've been messing
around with her this week with the glove
but
the glove we gotta what is too small
for a [__] softball i don't even know
what i was gonna say to you
[__]
or if it didn't even matter but the week
[__] changed now
so uh we're gonna start playing softball
that no
oh so i went to the [__] field
and the kids played and mercy hit the
[__] out of that ball
she was just having a problem catching
and whatever and then about three
o'clock
it started getting a little cold and the
wind started coming in so one of the
parents was like anybody hungry
man my wife was like we could eat so
she the one couple they just uh you know
that just a nice cup
all all of them are nice that's why i
spent new year's eve with
these these people was a bigger in a
bigger setting
my daughter and ned their son plays
together and they're great
the kid's great so we went to eat
and as i get up i'm walking towards the
door i got my mask on
there was maybe 18 people in the
restaurant and the weirdest thing
happened to me like this is
some kid just came out of nowhere he
goes hey how about a picture
and i looked at him like oh without even
[__] breaking beat
i just went nope and i just kept [__]
walking
and the lady that was with my wife
you know because they were all talking
about the lady that was talking to my
wife was next to me
and she goes is that how people treat
you
and i go no he's just a [__] jerk-off
that has no class his mother didn't
raise him right
she goes to people all the time i go
people come up to me and talk to me all
the time
do i love it if you're a gentleman or
you're a sweetheart of a girl
come up and talk to me come up and say
hello listen
uh i don't like your podcast but i like
young rogan
i don't like your jokes but i like your
podcast
i don't like your podcast but i like it
when you did ari's show i don't give a
[__]
if you're honest with me you want to
come up and talk to me talk to me you
know
i'm not going to take a picture with
anybody right now during covert
for your health and for my health let's
just stop with the [__] pictures okay
not right now in fact that's the second
picture i had to turn down since i've
been in jersey
which is a sweet thing for a guy like me
you know a couple weeks ago i was having
a i went to get lunch with my wife
and before i got out of the car you know
and some kid just knocked on the glass
never brushed his hair meanwhile i'm on
the phone with my [__] agent just
knocks in the glass he's looking let's
take a picture
you know get the [__] out of here take a
[__] hike no mask
no nothing it's covet season people
losing their lives
put your [__] camera away all right
put your little [__] camera away
because i'm not taking a picture with
nobody i don't want to feel responsible
for
me giving you covered and i don't want
to be on the other end of receiving
and since we don't know if you have it
or i haven't let's just shake hands
and part ways you want to come up to me
you want to say hello
say hello to you know people coming
through hey man say hello joe rogan for
me sure
whatever tell rogan to come here next
time yeah
i'll fly him up from austin to come in
at your restaurant in jersey
you know you don't know you have no
people you have no idea
so you know for me right now there ain't
no [__] pictures put your camera away
you want to talk to me come over and
talk people do it all the time
you know i mean don't come up to me at a
restaurant when i'm with my family at
the table
but if you see me at a park or something
like that come over say hello hey man i
like what you did on this
i didn't like what you saw on this
podcast and i'll talk with you
i'm gonna tell you what happened
remember a couple weeks after the
periscope
that kid no he reached out he reached
out and he apologized like a man
and i said because you apologizing that
made us
brothers that just made us brothers
thank you for apologizing now anything
you need
reach out to me on he's a patreon guy oh
really
yeah and he got my number and he wanted
a call and asked him how i treated him i
was like man
first of all i appreciate the [__]
honesty
that's it you'll never hear about this
again i'll never [__]
curse you he messaged me on patreon like
a man that he is
because listen if i'm your uncle i want
you to be a man the same way i'm a man
i'll tell you what's going on
treat me the [__] same way and we'll
be fine but don't just come up to me
like hey man
i bought a picture like he was trying to
show off in front of his friends and i
was like
nope and he just sat there his face
turned red and i just kept walking
because i don't give a [__] i hated
pictures you're from jersey in jersey
you're not supposed to be taking
pictures anyway so put the [__]
camera away [__]
and that's it and that's that that's
another episode
of the [__] joint for march 17
2021 the light is
almost dead don't go
don't get too excited yet there's still
another shoe that's going to drop
but for now the lights almost there at
the end of the tunnel pick yourself
up read a book go for a walk the
weather's starting to get nice
and that's it we're almost back guys
thank you
make your [__] plans but keep them
loose
because you never know what the other
shoes gonna drop right now
remember what i told you i love you
[__] with all my heart
have a great week i want to thank all
our sponsors
but now for a word for my [__]
sponsors
have a great weekend love you stay black
all right i want to thank you savages
for listening today i want to thank uh
nobody nobody came on i was all confused
it's just me alone
giving you [__] in here beating
like while they scout a guy in spanish
on patreon i just give
you a [__] ear beating in spanish
once a week on mondays but anyway
the joint is brought to you by gabby
insurance gabby gabi
we're all looking on ways to save money
right now especially now
so let me ask you this how'd you like
that how'd you like to save an extra 961
a year in your pocket that's how much
gabby customers save per year on their
home
and car insurance before you go looking
for insurance
talk to gabby i did and i saved money i
might i had to get a car i had a lease i
turned it in la
and when i got here i had to release a
new car when i they gave me a binder on
a friday i didn't know who to come i
said let me give gabby a shot
tremendous my wife said i'm saving no no
i don't know how many hundreds i'm
saving from what i was paying in la
compare what you got with 40 of the top
insurance providers like progressive
nationwide and travelers
just link your current insurance account
and in about two minutes
you'll be able to see the quotes from
the exact same coverage you currently
have
listen man i'm talking about saving
money a couple dollars here a couple
dollars there
you know we don't when we move to jersey
we don't have to pay for water no more
no more water tanks the jersey water's
nice and sweet they got drugs in there
you go crazy so you save money so we
save money with the water
every any any any opportunity i can save
you guys money i will that's why i'm
telling you
to check out gabby insurance right now
so do me a favor you're probably
overpaying on your car
and your home insurance see how much
gabby can save you
it's totally free to check and there's
no obligation
it's free to check just go to gabby.com
gabi.com joey
and give it a whoop it's free if you
could save some money if i could save
you two
three four five six seven eight nine
hundred dollars
you wouldn't love uncle joey even more
and you love them now come on give me a
breather
go to gabby dot com slash uncle joey
again go to gabby.com uncle joey and
just take a look take a chance columbus
did
the joint is also brought to you by oh
jesus christ
draftkings from the [__] heart of new
jersey
listen listen this is the biggest time
of the year it's march
and some people call it march madness
whatever the hell you want to call it
at draftkings it's march and saturday
here it is they're gonna give you 64 to
one odds
this is crazy you bet four thousand
underdog
if they win you're up 256 dollars
and you keep going who's gonna win you
think you know well
take a chance columbus dude put your
money where your [__] mouth is all it
takes is four dollars
to get a shot at winning 256 dollars
you can't wait to wait what do you go to
the atm that's spitting 20s at you
and [__] all around you everybody
wants to suck your dick why
because uncle joey turns you off to
draftkings there's no
better way to put your college
basketball knowledge to the test than to
put your money where your mouth is
with draftking sportsbook college ball
ain't for you that's okay
nba golf hockey and so much more
and they got great odds and promotions
and
they have boosts they have listen it is
just
fun you go on there if you're looking to
make
real money like if you're the real deal
holyfield you're not going to get in
trouble
for me it's fun i'm not doing nothing on
the tuesday night i go i look
i call the philly godfather or danny b
uh
wins boom they give me a game i bet it
you want me to tell what i bet 50
dollars 35 hours just to watch the game
and have some fun
on draftkings the number one sports book
app
out so do me a favor right now
draftkings is safe
secure reliable you withdraw your money
when you want it's your [__] money
so what what what are we doing here
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now use the luck of the irish it's
a [__] lucky day today
today's your [__] day download
the draftking sportsbook
app right now today use promo code joy
when you sign up
you turn four dollars into 256 dollars
if the underdog of your choosing pulls
off the upset
that's code joey to turn four dollars
into 256 dollars and it's only for a
limited time only
only at the draftking sportsbook app the
best
here's the part the lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 year
years older go roller skating i don't
know what to tell you
bet on [__] pigeons that you shoot
with your little rickshaw i don't know
new jersey indiana pa tennessee
new customers only restrictions apply
see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem i don't want to make it
worse
call 1-800 gambler or in indiana 1-809
with it
but if you're straight let me tell you
something this is the weekend to get
your party started
turn four dollars into 256 dollars
by downloading the draftking sports book
app now tell him uncle joey sent you
i want to thank draftkings i want to
thank gabby insurance i want to thank
[__] uh the people who shave your
balls manscaped
i want to thank everybody who was part
of the team this week i love all you
[__] with all my heart
but i'm talking to you guys i love you
guys you know i got your back thank you
for watching monday
and thank you for enjoying today's
podcast i love you [__] with all
my heart
stay black have a good weekend and we'll
see you monday morning
tip top magoo
[Music]
you